[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom from life where we
sits our philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host often break salad today we're
talking about protests and policing and
the question of who watches the Watchmen
or to use earlier formulation of that
that we see in in Plato remembering back
to our intro to philosophy days who
guards the Guardians and this is a major
issue right now as all across our nation
we're seeing protests some of which are
being dealt with in we could say fair
and just ways and others that are being
dealt with by quite a bit of violence on
the part of police and provocation and
the use of all sorts of tactics and
technology that places them at an
immense advantage and you know we're
gonna get into a lot of different issues
here but I think one of the things that
we could start by by talking about is
that you know all of this broke out or
was catalyzed by the George Floyd
killing and the the lack of reaction on
the part of the city of Minneapolis to
it and for a lot of people this was it
wasn't the last straw but it you know a
catalyst is something that in Kemp the
chemical terms brings things out of out
of a solution that they're in so that
they can precipitate out there's there's
always got to be something in the
background and at this point there's so
much in the background of what's going
on that it's brought out hundreds of
thousands of people across the nation
in a time of pandemic so people are
putting their own lives at risk and you
know what is the one central issue that
a lot of this revolves around police
aggression and brutality particularly
against members of the african-american
community and what we've seen on the
side of the police some people have kind
of made this into a joke but it but it's
not something really that's a laugh
about is that the police are in many
cases using exact
the sorts of things that were being
protested against to try to break the
protests so this really is a question of
who watches the Watchmen who guards the
the guardians and and this goes all the
way back to Plato and the Republic right
and the idea was that you need you need
some people who are particularly
courageous or spirited to be the police
to be the military to be the protectors
of everyone and you think about what
police are supposed to be doing the
motto is protect and serve protect right
and so that is what allows them to have
the authority that they're given and the
discretion and the capacity to use
deadly violence the fact that they're
supposed to be protecting that is the
end that is the purpose that is the the
primary reason to have police it's not
all the other things to like keep make
sure that windows don't get broken it's
to protect people and when police become
predatory and they're no longer
protecting but instead attacking their
flock Plato saw this as a problem all
the way back in that time he said
they're like dogs that you know attack
the Sheep and that has you know that
something has to be done about that what
were you gonna say Dan it's with George
Floyd it's just the whole idea of the
catalyst and you see this over and over
and over and every time we have a
incident where people like this is going
too far there's always like oh well he
did this or you know it was in the
situation in the moment but the the I
want to say one of the things that helps
make this a catalyst was that it was
like eight and a half minutes of him
slowly murdering this person and it's so
unable for anyone to say that that
action was not justified that that it
was unjustified yeah it was it was
absolutely there's no way that you could
make an argument that it was justified
yeah there's been a lot of dodges the
medical examiner translate pre-existing
conditions you know and my response to
that when
we're posting that was well that's why
nobody shouldn't yell on anybody's neck
for any amount of time because who knows
who has pre-existing conditions you
don't take risks like that if you're
doing it and then you know adding to it
the fact that it was being video
recorded and the cops didn't care they
were perfectly fine with people watching
them kill somebody and the other three
cops keeping keeping people at bay which
which tells you that there's more to the
story right it tells you that they think
they can act with complete impunity and
that they're gonna be protected and in
in today's America largely because of
legislation to absolve police
departments from blame and poor
leadership yes we have allowed there to
be set up a situation in which the
police largely are not accountable
exactly yeah and I can't put like me I
can't think of the name of the
particular case at the moment but the
one that set the precedent that on any
instance in which a police officer is
has the feeling that they might right
have bodily damaged yeah they can use
deadly force and it can be an instant it
can be like you know a nanosecond and
and that will give them cover to do
whatever yeah and you know this is
something I think this might be a topic
for us to explore at another time and
I've been thinking a lot about this the
notion that a again you know police
officers are supposed to be courageous
if we think about the classic thing so
the the idea that they can say oh I was
in fear of my life when they were
heavily armed and oftentimes had all
sorts of advantages over whoever it was
that they were you know going to be
contending with her bringing force to
bear on to me just seems like an
outright lie
and you know it's it's bad enough that
there's killing right unjust killing the
lying about it the cover-up makes it far
worse because it denies justice to the
victims and not just to the victims
themselves but to their families and to
the community to everybody who says that
could be me you see so many young
especially african-american but not just
them men saying wow I I could be in that
person's place and you know if there
wasn't a camera trained on me nobody
would even know I mean wouldn't save my
life but nobody would even know that the
story is recorded by the police after
the fact after they get their stories
straight would be taken as as the real
one and and you know you look back at
American history I mean again it's it's
we're enabled by the fact that that
people have felt that what they were
doing was somehow okay they'd actually
write down about say lynchings that they
did you know now we know that that
that's wrong and the police know it's
wrong too but they do it and they they
get away with it and so often and so
this was catalyzing there's so many
people I think not just within the
particularly affected communities but
all over the place who are like this is
too much this is this this is this is
the the time when you know it's it's
gone too far and then when they started
expressing that and others people
started pushing back you know what could
have happened quite easily would be
people push back and then everyone was
like oh yeah yeah you're right maybe we
don't won't take a stand on this one or
it could have been just like one day of
protests and in Minneapolis and a few
echoes around but instead what we have
is what seems to be a growing movement
right and that sustained movement is the
thing that it's going to actually cause
eventual change it's really interesting
I hold to the point right yeah it's
really interesting to the point where
when we all got cameras on our cell
phones on our persons all the time the
the rate in which we have UFO sightings
has dropped precipitously and the rate
of that release have been acting in
negative ways towards the populace has
gone way up well that's interesting yeah
what could have caused that you know in
it and it's not just having the capacity
to record I mean you think back to the
la Ronda que ya ya and and the fact that
there was a guy who had a video camera
because otherwise nobody would believe
Rodney King you know and it's not just
that we have the capacity to record
which which also works against us you
know the cops are going to be scouring
all the protester videos and things like
that for faces to try to bring them in
on things so it's not it's not a pure on
the side of the people sort of thing but
the fact that we have social networks is
incredibly important as well because
these videos then get on to Twitter and
Facebook they even make it on to the old
you know old-school cable news stuff
although the cable news at this point in
time seems to be doing a the well you
know there's both sides to the story
sort of sort of thing
it's it's also yeah it's very good yeah
and we should talk about that in just a
moment that false equivalence because it
is it is a fallacy right
and not only is it a fallacy in the
sense of being something that goes
against truth it's also unjust to engage
in but one of the things I wanted to say
very quickly before that is there's a
generational gap between those who get
most of their news from newspaper
websites and cable news where it's this
well you know both sides are doing
things we we really need to be balanced
with this and the younger generations
which are getting it largely from social
media and from opinion sites like say
Vox or slate or you know Atlantic where
they're they're seeing in almost in real
time if you're on Twitter it's almost in
real time now what's happening in cities
across the states and you get to see
that the people posting raw video of
police you know saying not just
attacking protesters but attacking
clergy and attacking press people and
attacking medical personnel really going
out going over the line and the super
cuts they're in you know this are
becoming like oh it's not like this
litany of things where we can like
actually put this to you know some
like a progression and and yeah I don't
know I guess some music you know turn
into a little bit of entertainment but
also it still pulls for things like
these things happen over and over and
over that you see them yeah and it's
it's overwhelming so let's talk about
this false equivalence thing for for
just a moment
we usually label this as a fallacy right
so what does that mean a fallacy is
something an argument that does not
always bring you to the truth the matter
and it's like the conclusion that you
get from a fallacious argument may or
may not be true but on there's no way
that you can know it's true from the
argument itself yeah so so that's
important in the realm of truth
what's wrong with using fallacies I mean
especially if the other side is using
fallacies is there is there something
bad about that I mean I think there is I
guess if you want to be an honest and
true water if you're just trying to be a
Sophos and you're just trying to
convince people they are based on no
truth then yeah fallacies are great but
if you actually want to get to the truth
of the matter the core of the issue then
you've got to avoid them as all costs I
suppose we could actually say that in in
many cases fallacies are what allow
groups that don't want to be in touch
with the truth that wanted an i reality
they allow them to have a group
cohesiveness through having a shared
story right yeah we talked about that
with on last week about wise blue lies
or yeah sure to share though let's
remind people with that that is so as
opposed to white lies lies to like save
face or preserve somebody else's
feelings or accomplish some sort of good
task and opposed to black lies where
you're just trying to hurt people period
blue in center yourself
yeah blue lies are somewhere in between
and this when you're protecting your
group you're telling a lie that furthers
the interests of your group but
but probably damages the interests of
another group so and this leads to
something that that you had wanted to
talk about earlier before we got on to
this about why are people denying what's
happened
yeah what are the motives for that that
people have I could definitely see that
in the context of their lives that like
you see this within I guess certain
religions have this like you know they
put a statement of faith and on and it
might be something that could be
potentially easily refuted as proven in
a different yeah but because I say it's
true and I that is me I guess to a
certain extent signaling to everyone
else in the group that I am part of the
group because we all believe the same
thing that no one else believes and yeah
and that would that actually increases
the cohesiveness of the group yeah the
same dynamic can happen in terms of you
know political organizations or social
classes or I mean it could happen in
terms of sports teams you see some of
the crazy things people have to say
about rival sports teams usually not
with such horrible effects it depends on
how bad the fan base is you know right
compare say Packers fans versus Eagles
fans kind of dangerous so there's
certain soccer hooligans yeah I was just
thinking this is a totally off topic but
we were at Lambeau I was at Lambeau for
the very first time this last year and
there were it was a Packers versus Bears
game and so these were you know big big
rivals right and because Chicago is
close enough to Milwaukee they can
easily drive up and I would say that
two-thirds of the people in the stands
were Packers fans and I would say that
the other third were were Bears fans or
or people just weren't wearing anything
you couldn't tell who they were for and
I didn't see any Packers fans treat
Bears fans badly
you know now that's unusual I think in
in quite a few places that you go and
you're wearing the other team's thing I
mentioned Philly great example they will
abuse you and and and some of that has
to do with this sort of in-group
cohesion that we were just talking about
and it can be quite quite bad and it can
lead us to ignoring in justices that
have I mean if we get away from the
silliness of sports and talk about like
generations of injustice towards
minorities here in Milwaukee it's a
prime example we're still one of the
most segregated large cities in the
United States even though we've you live
in one area River West which is pretty
desegregated and I live here in the
downtown which is desegregated if you
were just looking at those areas you
wouldn't you wouldn't notice what the
rest of the city looks like right right
and there's and there's historical
reasons for that you know redlining and
yeah and the police have played a role
in in that as well so so we should jump
in to talk about yes talk about negative
peace and positive okay and so I was
reading a little bit from I guess the
whole thing MLK is letter from the
Birmingham jail and this this passage
really is very impactful I've been
greatly disappointed with the white
moderate I have almost reached a
regrettable conclusion to the Negroes
great stumbling block in the astride
towards freedom is not the white citizen
counselor or the Klu Klux Klan er but
the white mater who is more devoted to
order than to justice who prefers a
negative peace which is the absence of
tension to a positive peach peace which
is the presence of justice who
constantly says I agree with you but you
in the goal you seek but I can't agree
with your methods or a direct action uh
uh who feels that he can set the
timetable for another's freedom who
lives by the
of time and who constantly advises the
negro to wait until a more convenient
season yeah yeah Martin Luther King's
letter from a Birmingham jail is is a
really important piece to read you know
there's been a lot of discussion of
Martin Luther King in the last couple
days in light of the George Floyd thing
because a lot of people have said you
know he's the person who all of the what
he's calling white moderates and
nowadays we call them liberals will
bring up and say we've got to make sure
everything has remains totally
nonviolent and it's true that Martin
Luther King was a advocate of nonviolent
direct action after by the way having
been an advocate of armed self-defense
he changed his mind and he changed his
mind in a robust and rigorous way there
was nothing namby-pamby or sort of you
know let's let's just all kumbaya get
together and get along sort of stuff
with it
he was seriously committed to it and
it's true that that white conservatives
and white liberals love Martin Luther
King because they love to not read
Martin Luther King they love kale I love
the idea of let's all be nice and get
along and they they memorized one or two
lines from the I have a dream speech but
if you really read the letter from a
Birmingham jail it's an indictment of
not only the Society at that time but
you know our cities and small towns and
suburbs right now as well and and just
later on in the letter he talks about
how on if you don't work with us as the
nonviolent right then you're going to
force the hand and move these people to
those more violent groups that are still
going about to the same goals and that
he talks about specifically the
Brotherhood of Islam and how the nation
in his lone Nation of Islam thank you
and how they basically have no Buy in
they believe that the the current
government and society has no place for
them and so they have no problem
in violence yeah and you could say that
there was I mean there was a contrast
between Martin Luther King and Malcolm X
Malcolm max you know the phrase everyone
associates with him is by any means
necessary there were some strictures
that even he thought you had to follow
but the the entire Black Power movement
that was not devoted to nonviolent
direct action looked at what Martin
Luther King was doing is essentially
giving in but I think Martin Luther King
was able Martin Luther King and we
should always remember all the people
that were surrounding him and working
with him were able to accomplish what
they they did because there was that
that well if you're not going to deal
with us you're gonna deal with these
guys over here and they're not gonna be
as forgiving the other thing I'll say
too is you know Martin Luther King drew
quite a bit on on Gandhi who also had a
philosophy of non-violent activism and
when Gandhi was asked about resisting
the British he said well you know we can
appeal to their consciences and that's
the key thing if you can't appeal to the
conscience of the those who are engaging
and unjust
oppression exploitation suppression all
these these sorts of things if you're
dealing with Attila the Hun there's no
such thing as nonviolent direct action
in that case you have to use violence
against them and so you know if you know
this isn't what Martin Luther King is
saying but if you extend that logic
further if there's a side that is going
to try to use whatever tricks and
whatever lies and whatever force they
can use and essentially terrorizing
people to further their side well maybe
then they can't be reasoned with and
it's up to you know the people who are
at risk of falling into that to pull
themselves back from the precipice I
think you know if the if the police
forces were really to become just a
bunch of armed thugs then I think we
would have a moral duty to all rise up
against them quite frankly but it's not
it's not at that point there it is
possible to appeal to people's
conscience
and so that makes it imperative to keep
making the case over and over again that
that what we need here is is to see
justice being done not a suppression of
protest but actually allowing it to go
on you know and I think that can be done
while still protecting human life and
protecting property and all these other
things that are indeed important but the
the priority here really has to be
bringing these these festering issues
out into the open and allowing people to
express what's wrong with with police
violence directed systematically at
minorities over years and years and
years you know so this is exactly you
you look at this letter it's like a
scathing polemic which is I guess a
scathing rebuke of certain positions in
their talk he talks about like how in
Birmingham specifically is like the
number one place where people are on on
investigated bombings of black homes and
churches and so this this negative peace
is this like this false sense of peace
that there's just there's not fighting
on the streets because one group has so
restricted the rights of the other that
that they won't openly engage but it
doesn't mean that the problem the basis
of that problem has actually gone away
hid simmer Nancy's right under the
surface and is waiting like you know I
guess a blister that is wanting to be
popped you know and I think going back
to talking about the technology I think
in this age of interconnectedness those
sorts of things can't be hidden away as
effectively as they were in the past you
know if you I mean why do we know about
so many police killings not only of
african-american young men I mean I even
think about that that one white guy who
was ordered by the cop to like you know
lay down
and the cop started shooting him up
anyway you know and we know about that
precisely because we've seen the videos
because they're there in social media
and so I think the you know the the
people who think that they're gonna get
away with stuff and cover it up they may
not go to jail but people know about it
public public opinion is able to latch
on to it in a way that it wasn't able to
in the past right like you know the
reason why we're here we're recording
exactly cost to entry into getting your
voice out is so much lower than it used
to be you say like had to buy a printing
press and ink and paper and distribute
that stuff and that was a lot of things
to do and undertaking this is like yeah
I don't know how excited to take us yeah
I think that and I think that's an
important thing to keep in mind it's
it's a good thing to be able to
encourage those who are going to be
pushing for change and and the push for
change it's not going to be done this
summer and it's not going to be over
just with the November election I think
this is one of those cases where there
there is something that's happening now
and there is some forward momentum but
it's going to have to be you know I keep
coming back to this phrase that I
learned from my wife who keeps using it
well I mean it's it's almost meta in
this way it's consistent pressure
relentlessly applied you know I think
that's that's what we're gonna have to
use it's not gonna be like narratives
where the you know we were talking about
Star Wars earlier where we blow up the
Death Star and and you know now you know
we have the the everyone gets a medal
and and we're you know we're good until
the next movie it's gonna be little
steps here in their consolidating gains
and you know another thing that this is
going to take you know we're getting
actually quite away from some of the
points we're going to talk about but I
think this is quite important change is
not going to happen without buy-in
ultimately also from the people who were
trying to change the in this case the
the police so you know we're going to
have to find ways to get rid of a lot of
bad cops and I get rid of I mean get
them fired get them out of get them out
of being police and and not not in the
sense where they get fired in one
department and go three suburbs down and
get hired at another one there's gonna
have to be a lot of screening and a lot
of holding leadership accountable and
and all of that but if we want there to
be good policing we're gonna have to
we're not gonna just be able to say you
know all cops are bastards or anything
like that that's not that's not going to
be that may be a nice thing to say when
we're you know riling people up actually
my son said that earlier today to me on
the phone in a discussion but we don't
we don't want them all to be bastards
you know we want them ultimately to be
protectors and there may be some things
in you know in the nature of policing
that are rather corrosive and we have to
target those we have to we have to make
police actually care about ethics and
accountability and that's gonna be a
tough thing to do you know so we're
gonna have to push and push and push and
push and push yes I think I said all
thing kind of well I think some people
are gonna run out of steam inevitable
right right and that means that other
people are gonna have to step up at that
point and carry on the thing but I I
think what we're seeing here now really
is a historical turning point and so
this this really makes me think you know
we're gonna jump around a little bit
here yeah but down to the three point
five percent rule yeah talk about that
so this is Erica Chenoweth and Maria Jay
Stephan who are both PhDs and they were
have been working on on different
aspects of what causes you know either
revolutions or just political change and
they did a a meta-analysis and others
meta-analysis its analysis of historical
events from 1900 up to 2006 and they
found that if you can get three point
five percent of the population to join
an active and sustained
protests it succeeds every single
position of protest on that is either
I'm violent or not and that gets three
point five percent of the population to
buy in and actually participate on
either results in the government
adopting the positions of the protesters
or the disintegrates the country and so
you guys see that in like Egypt and
Tunisia where during the what if you
have counters or movements where like
you've got you've got your three point
five but then there's another three
point five on the other side and they're
pushing back on the sames I know she
doesn't go quite into it but it makes me
think
I guess Egypt again where there was the
Arab Spring thing and then there was
also in the Muslim Brotherhood that was
also pushing and and they weren't they
were just both pushing for the ouster of
I believe it was Mubarak yeah at the
moment but there was definitely the
Muslim Brotherhood group and the the
other group and their ends weren't the
same even though the the means to get to
their ends were the same and so they
work together
yeah they had very different different
visions of what Egypt should look like
after the military dictatorship was gone
and so this whole idea of like being
sustained and and constantly pushing and
pushing and if you get a large enough
portion of the population to join you
then you can push it over the top the
problem is that violent campaigns are
only attract about a fourth on average
of the people that nonviolent ones do
and so you actually have if you if you
can sustain a non-violent campaign is
actually one of the ways that you can
get enough people to actually join you
and that idea is one of the reasons why
people that oppose particular protests
are so happy to try to paint the
protesters in any way as violent you
know
the things that I had wanted to bring up
is and again I'll use my my kid as a
example
he was talking about you know we should
riot and I said you want to avoid that
word you know that that plays exactly
into the hands of those who want to see
an end to the protest and everyone does
just shut up and get back to work
protest is what's happening and protest
is something that is not I mean
Americans love to appeal to the
Constitution but this is something that
is acknowledged as a moral right
basically in every functioning democracy
that's what makes it a democracy the
fact that you can protest not just that
we have voting and things like that but
that you can actually express yourself
within organized civil society and in
ongoing ways and so interests of
grievances yeah exactly I mean I mean if
we can if we can protest like you know
companies changing the formula of their
potato chips which people do you know
they get on Twitter and rail about it
well it's all all the more important
that we be able to protest about things
that really do matter
you know our politics and the nature of
our society and how we distribute
justice and who the police think falls
upon and who goes to jail and who
doesn't so I think you know when we're
thinking about what's going on the the
side let's call them the side across
from the police because the police are
lined up in lines not generally not
engaged in dialogue or anything like
that they're lined up facing a group of
people so the group of people consists
largely of protesters and that's that's
what they are and they are nonviolent
and then we have some people who are
there to to riot and like you know this
usually in Milwaukee is happening after
curfew you know some of them are there
to break windows and loot things but
they are a tiny minority you know
they're by far not what the movement at
present is about and then we have some
other instigators that are there too
you're up stuff for for other reasons
it's not just selfish it's because
they've got some sort of ideological
beef and some of them are from the far
right some of them are from the far left
and again very small minorities the vast
majority in each of the the places that
that I've actually been able to see it
I've looked at a lot what's going on a
lot of these American city protests are
people who are engaging in essentially
nonviolent direct action
yeah the vast majority of them see that
and you know I would actually add one
more group which has got a unfortunate
long history in the United States mmm
and all over the world are you know
counterintelligence program Oh
infiltrated agent provocateurs
and you know if you're not familiar with
it you should probably become familiar
with continental Pro which was a program
that ran through from 1956 to 71 in the
FBI under you know our best friend j
edgar Hoover in order to basically try
to stamp out the quote-unquote
subversives and and basically it was
just a campaign to either discredit from
the outside to try to pull up dirt of
leaders to create dirt on to infiltrate
and cause this order and discord within
the groups to infiltrate into protests
to either on start violence themselves
or to instigate violence in others and
all the way up to assassinations of
leadership within these groups yeah you
know and it wasn't just an America to
the Brits had their own intelligence
people doing that with their their own
leftist movements and and I think this
is this is kind of a common thing you
know this so a little bit off topic here
but if you think about the resources
that are devoted to carrying out that
sort of infiltration it's not something
that you can do on the cheap and that
money has to come from somewhere and
where is where is it coming from it's
coming from the taxpayers it's coming
from the the people who are you know the
ones who are upset about things so and
we can say the same thing about the
police you know one of the issues with
the the Minneapolis Police Department is
that it's so well funded Forbes did an
article a while back and they looked at
all these big metropolitan police forces
Minneapolis was spending over 30 percent
of their budget on policing that's an
awful lot that's not being devoted to
schools to public health to all the
other things that we you know we really
need instead you know they're they're
given all this money and then they buy
riot gear with it and they you know pay
for lawsuits and all these these other
things to essentially create their their
police as a protected class you know
another thing that we could probably go
on and on about this all day but another
big problem with with police and this is
a problem here in Milwaukee is that they
don't have to reside in the places that
they're policing I don't know if you
remember that movie Copland the it's
very interesting it kind of went under
the radar it didn't get a lot of
accolades as far as I remember but it
was quite good it was about New York
City and it was about this this small
suburb town where all these cops lived
who actually worked in the city and they
would get around the housing things by
having like in a little apartment in the
city that they could claim residency and
but they actually lived outside of the
city so that they could you know do
their own thing and and the local
sheriff under covered corruption and
then he was pressured not to do anything
about it the sheriff's played by
Sylvester Stallone not a great actor Oh
obviously you know it's not going to get
get a lot of accolades for that but the
basic idea was if you're not actually in
the community
that you're serving it's going to be
harder to identify with the people in
the community and to care about them and
not just to see it as us versus them as
being an occupying force which is what's
part of what's happening right now I
think we have a similar problem too and
we call out the National Guard
you know these National Guard's people
they don't have a stake in Milwaukee
unless they're from Milwaukee you know
right and if you're not part of the
group then you're a no it kind of makes
me think of the ancient Spartans and
they thank God things aren't that bad I
always saw themselves as an occupying
force there because they yeah they were
an occupying force technically that's
quite true what was the yeah so that I
mean the Spartans were essentially an
invading people who superimposed their
rule on a much broader population who
they enslaved and maintained in slavery
that entire time every once in a while
they'd revolt and then they'd be put
down with really bloody reprisals and
they were you know the part of the
Spartan ethos was to be predatory on
these people it's interesting that when
you bring up the Spartans Aristotle in
the politics talks about the Spartans
and as opposed to like say Socrates and
Plato who kind of admired them to some
degree but also thought they were
corrupt Aristotle thought that the
Spartans were really misguided that they
had essentially they were sort of like
an animal he didn't use this metaphor
but they're sort of like an animal that
had bred itself for one purpose and got
really good at that purpose and became
really crappy at everything else so
Aristotle talks about them is you know
being really great soldiers and
preparing for war and up until that time
the Spartans really hadn't been beaten
in battle by by anybody although later
on theat the Thebes would beat them the
the the sacred band would would destroy
the Spartan record in that respect and
Aristotle said well that's great you're
great at fighting
you're terrible and everything else
because you you made that the center of
your existence this struggle for
dominance and honor you know think about
the way that that Trump was talking just
the other day you have to dominate he's
telling the state governors well that's
foolish talk
you don't dominate a free people that
you actually care about and value that's
the way that a oppressor talks you know
that's not the way somebody who wants to
get people to buy in and and think that
we live in a society together talks the
Spartan sound like several hundred years
of negative peace exactly yeah yeah and
they and and you know when everybody
around you has that mindset you don't
know any better that's that's the best
you can hope for
so negative peace right what's positive
peace look like aa positive peace is a
true and lasting and sustainable peace
built on harmony and justice and equity
for all people so is there a here's a
question is that something that you can
attain once and for all
no yeah keep on working for that because
that thing is you know always crumbling
yeah so the people who always you you
know we addressed your problems
we gave you some handouts or however
they want to frame it why can't you just
be happy and you know not protest
they're they're not for a positive peace
then they're there for a negative peace
right right I think part of what would
be required is it's all I'm gonna bring
in another philosopher who's still alive
right now you're gonna Hamas one of the
key thinkers of discourse ethics and I
know one of the things you want to talk
about is the social contract so so Hamas
talks about something like this we have
a you could say buy-in that has to
happen we have to figure out what kind
of society we're gonna have and it's
something that we have to continually
re-evaluate and continually remake and
we do that by talking with each other
and by the way III meant or actually sat
down with Hamas at a conference and did
precisely that's the sort of haves and
the have-nots at this this philosophy
conference split up into two groups and
we're not physically but you know ret
rhetorically at each other's throats
Harbor masa actually called like a
meeting of everybody and sat down and
put some you know drinks on the table
and said okay we're gonna hash this out
and what we what you do is you treat
your interlocutors as somebody who
actually has something to say has
something to contribute they're not just
an enemy across the table there's
somebody that you can deal with and you
work out norms that can be acceptable to
everybody and you don't stop until you
can get at least some consensus some
buy-in and the only way to do that is to
take risks to be willing to say okay we
were wrong in doing this we apologize
what would it take to make this right
you know and that takes a lot of courage
on the part of those who have benefited
and Exploited and you know maybe for
those people that see that's saying that
they're wrong is a mark of weakness
that's a big problem right yeah I guess
a lot of people some people just will
never admit that they're wrong
and then others they worry that if they
you know the proverbial give an inch
they'll take a mile if I say that I'm
wrong and I apologize for this then
they'll talk about the other 20 things I
didn't apologize for you know yeah so I
would like you to go into a little bit
on the higher law oh that Martin Luther
King talks about in the letter from a
Birmingham jail right and how that like
intersects with you know Cicero and
Augustine Aquinas yeah so it's in the
Western traditions it goes all the way
back to Cicero the Stoics and also to
Aristotle Aristotle talks about
something like this even Sophocles has
Antigone talk about a higher law that's
proceeds that of the city so this is a
long-standing concept and you can also
find a similar thing in Indian
philosophy and Chinese philosophy I
think it's something that's kind of a
constant this notion that whatever laws
we currently have in place and whatever
rulers whatever we're gonna call them
the executive the magistrate you know
the people who make the decisions on the
spot and then the people who direct them
none of them get to say that like Judge
Dredd I am the law all right they're all
accountable to something higher so
they're measured by it
and you know this this could come from
different sources
Cicero thought that it was sort of built
into the fabric of nature as part of
what's inherent in rationality Thomas
Aquinas thought it came from God
ultimately the natural law is a
reflection of the eternal law Augustine
talks about this but they all agree in
this that if a law is going to be if a
human law a practice a norm an executive
order is going to be just it cannot be
out of sync with the higher moral law if
it is it loses its legitimacy so for
example using the military to attack
protesters that goes against the the
moral law I mean if they and you could
say well what if those protesters were
themselves armed like the ones who are
storming state houses earlier and they
were firing I am well they're not
protesters at that point now there's
something different now they are armed
belligerence and you can use force
against them insofar as they remain
protesters you can't use deadly force
against them or potentially deadly force
that is a violation of the moral law and
those who engage in it and those who
command it should be held to standards
as we see for example you know a little
bit of breaking news by the time that
we're this is actually playing it's it's
been in several days but
a little bit of breaking news as that
former defense secretary mattis
unequivocally condemned president
Trump's use of troops to clear out the
capital so he could have his photo ops
and he you know he's not mincing any
words in saying that there was an abuse
of executive authority in Lafayette
Square now I think what he's doing there
is he's referring to the same moral law
higher law that say Martin Luther King
would have been referring to MLK he's
got a couple quotes here on unjust lousy
unjust law as a code that the majority
inflicts on a minority that is not
binding on itself and a yes law is a
code that a majority compels a minority
to follow and that is willing to follow
itself that's a key name dismayed yeah
yeah that being living up to the very
standards that you're attempting to
impose on somebody else that is of the
essence of being a moral person bad
people make excuses for themself and
impose what they can't themselves do on
other people and you know another thing
to keep in mind too is Martin Luther
King that I think is particularly
important in our time
he said that law could be unjust as the
law itself so like if I have a law that
that requires me for example to go next
door and beat up my neighbor or also I'm
going to be fine okay that's an unjust
law right that that needs to go but a
law can also be unjust in its
application and this is where policing
comes in if a law is on its face just
but as its imposed unfairly on some
people and then it's not applied to
others that makes the law unjust
so if well let's take the example of
protesters right so the police did
nothing
absolutely nothing when we had people
breaking the law when it came to Cove
it'd going around with mat without masks
saying that they wouldn't do that
sometimes spitting on on police you know
not observing social distancing and
carrying weapons around that they
there's no reason they should have in
any civilized society regardless of what
what amendments there are you know they
were that people were carrying those
around just to terrorize that would that
was the reason for it they should have
all been arrested and thrown in jail and
disarmed and charged with all sorts of
things none of them were not a single
one and now because people want to
protest police brutality suddenly it's
okay to use you know teargas grenades
and shoot rubber bullets which aren't
actually rubber at people and to attack
the press and attack medical personnel
so that's a clear you know example of a
law that's unjust in its application
another one is you know there's a study
by the ACLU they went from 2001 to 2010
and looked at the arrest and conviction
rate of black and white individuals for
marijuana possession typically from 18
to 25 year olds in which you know about
2020 at 25 to 30 percent of both black
and white actually whites have more
usage than blacks in this particular
study
and so basically negligible difference
in the actual usage but the black youth
is not youth but whatever on 18 or 25
young people were four times more likely
yeah are four times more likely to be
arrested and seven to eight percent more
likely to be convicted and that is
definitely an incongruity in the
application of the law yeah and I mean
you can say we can
come up with all sorts of examples the
drug application of drug laws is a great
example sentencing is another prime
example the whole stop and frisk thing
that was finally brought up in a useful
way in in the democratic debates clearly
applied much more heavily to minority
communities than to the white community
and so those are those are some of the
things that create underlying I don't
even want to say resentments because
resentments almost implies as if there
isn't a good reason to be upset about
these things these are legit these are
things that people ought to be
legitimately upset about and those of us
who are not particularly impacted about
it we should be indignant that that's an
emotion that I think we ought to feel it
we shouldn't be like oh well I'm glad it
doesn't you know affect me you know
lucky lucky where it where I ended up in
society instead we should be like well
this is nonsense that that you know
we're using our resources to police
these people and not these people
you know we're distributing harms over
here and distributing all the nice
benefits over here that should bother us
I think now this is this is a great
place for us to talk a little bit about
well how how should we get bothered you
know you and I are both co-leaders of
the Milwaukee stoic fellowship somebody
might say well that's not very stoic of
you to say that you should get bothered
I think that it's perfectly fine to feel
an emotion of righteous indignation you
don't use that as your sole guidance or
fuel or your motivation yeah and you
don't want to like stay upset all the
time but you know like Seneca says
anything that you can accomplish with
anger you can accomplish with reason you
can you can stick with it there's this
this view that as rational beings who
have a common social nature and care
about each other we can be emotionally
involved and rational at the same time
and sort of stick with what we need to
do and you can't fall into that you know
indifference trap that just because
you don't have the direct control over
the situation and the outcomes that you
shouldn't act you're compelled to act on
regardless because you are
yes working for the betterment of your
your the polis the gender the the
cosmopolitan the entire group the whole
of the world yeah there's that and then
there's also another resource I think
there is in stoicism is I mean Epictetus
says that our duties are our obligations
are revealed to us by our the names that
we bear though the ways in which we
describe ourselves so if I describe
myself as a fellow citizen of the United
States or fellow resident of Wisconsin
or fellow resident of Milwaukee and I
see my fellow residents being oppressed
by the police for talking about how the
police have been oppressing people I
have a duty to those people because
they're members of my community to stick
up for them to care about them so you
know to be very direct we are saying a
practice that you can do is to go and go
to the protest yourself you know one to
support the cause but also if you are
are fearful of what it is to be in a
protest if you're don't know but if you
have this misunderstanding of what they
are doing going there and being in the
thick of it will really remove that fear
Road that fear that you might have had
beforehand especially you go like during
the daytime you know yeah don't go in
like like two o'clock in the morning
right you know was that old adage
nothing good happens after 2:00 a.m.
yeah that that's true you know III think
that that some people who would be leery
of doing that would would say well you
know I don't want to be like advocating
what they're doing I don't want to be
mistaken for being one of the protesters
do you think there's there's a risk of
that
I think really small risk or maybe finds
a protest that you find a little bit
more benign if this one for some reason
is not your cup of tea but like just due
to experience the event of getting
together and saying we think there's
something wrong with our society at the
moment and we are going to make our
voices known that we don't enjoy that
and it one of these things here is this
idea of courage and courage being
synonymous with some sort of violence
and I I would like to try it being a
couple that's courageous right yeah
because nonviolent action is courageous
it because it gets results that we
looked at earlier the three point five
percent rule here it doesn't need to be
violent it can be nonviolent it can
cause massive systemic change it takes
more courage not to just swing at people
I think in a lot of cases you know you
gotta buzz people think someone just
provoked me what about people who can't
effectively go out and protest like
those who already are sick or are you
know at risk of let's say they have a
compromised immune systems or they're
living with people who that could be a
problem with what what can they do so
there's there's a number of things you
can either support them by either
support like giving them monetary
support or like material support food
water or whatnot and you can try to
share the message online we have that
ability nowadays rather loosely there
are distributed tactics like in Iran
where they would like every night at a
certain time would get out and they'd
yell and bang pots on their roofs
because they were being militarily shut
down and so they they kept the protest
going even in face of violence by
distributing the protest yeah well those
all sound like good things to do and
what what if somebody is you know not
quite sure whether they where they fit
in right now with the whole situation I
think there are some people who are can
offense sitting what would you say to
them and come to a decision right right
you have to come to a decision at some
point in time you really shouldn't be
been sitting at this one okay well any
any final thoughts to lead us out on so
I've got a little book from captain
Adama of Battlestar Galactica there's a
reason that you separate the military
and the police one fights the enemy of
the States and the other one serves to
protect the people when the military
becomes both then the enemies of the
state tend to become so say we all
[Music]
you